les journées se suivent et se
ressemblent pour la birmanie
ce samedi cent sept personnes dont sept
enfants ont été déclarées mortes par les
nations unies ce qui en fait le jour le
plus sanglant depuis le coup d'état du
1er février dernier
les forces de sécurité continuent d'user
de balles réelles contre la population
qui ne cessent de manifester à travers
le pays depuis quasiment deux mois
les virements ne veulent pas céder sous
la pression des militaires et demandent
toujours le rétablissement de la
démocratie
un bilan macabre qui a scandalisé la
communauté internationale fait est
terrible c'est absolument scandaleux et
d'après les informations que j'ai reçu
beaucoup de personnes ont été tuées de
manière complètement inutile l'union
européenne a de son côté condamné les
actes des militaires c'est une escalade
de la violence inacceptable c'est une
voix un sens est emprunté par la junte
gérer iter la condamnation par lieu de
la violence aveugle exercée contre le
peuple de birmanie et j'exhorte les
dirigeants militaires à abandonner cette
voie insensé cette tragédie doit cesser
les chefs d'état-major militaire de 12
pays comptant les états unis le japon
l'allemagne ou encore la grande-bretagne
ont eux aussi désapprouvé les
agissements de l'armée en tant que chef
d'état major nous condamnons usage de la
force létale contre des personnes non
armées par les forces armées de la
birmanie et les services de sécurités
associés une armée professionnelle sur
les normes internationales de conduite
et à la responsabilité de protéger le
peuple qu'elle sert non de lui nuire
ce dimanche de nombreuses funérailles
ont été organisées à travers le pays
pour rendre hommage aux birmans décédé
dans la répression des manifestations
depuis le coup d'état de la junte le 1er
février dernier au moins 423 personnes
ont été tuées et malgré les sanctions
annoncées par les différents pays et
organismes internationaux
la junte militaire ne semble vouloir
donner aucun signe d'ouverture ou
d'apaisement